hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast vitamin D health disparities
and prostrate cancer and Alzheimer's I'm
Robert castellanos of labatts and I'll
be a moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminars presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon at the
lower right-hand corner of the slide
window if it any technical problems
feeling or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the bring to an a button lower left this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C button located on the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of attaining your
credits unlike to introduce today's
speaker dr. Sebastiano gotelli jelly dr.
Cataldo jelly received his MD from the
University of Naples medical school
before completing his menacing oncology
at the Catholic University Medical
School renown on the fellowship of
molecular biology and New York
University Medical Center he is
currently a professor radiation oncology
at the Medical University of South
Carolina and health research scientist
at the ralphs Asia Johnson VA Medical
Center in Charleston South Carolina for
the past decade vitamin d3
supplementation studies have been an
important aspect of his research efforts
specifically he has explored the impact
the hypervitaminosis d can have on the
health of very large segments of the
population he is currently
I mean the possibility that long-term
vitamin D deficiency may contribute to
the progression of subclinical prostrate
cancer to clinical disease especially
among african-american men he is
actively conducting clinical trials to
determine whether vitamin d3
supplementation and patients diagnosed
with early-stage low-risk prostate
cancer will yield improved therapeutic
clinical and survival outcomes I'll now
turn it over to the doctor for his
presentation hello everyone
my name is Sebastiano kerkovich le and
and we'll discuss today some of my work
results of my work on vitamin D prostate
cancer in african-americans and towards
the end of my presentation some
interesting observations which had to do
with vitamin D as a possible preventing
agent for Alzheimer's so vitamin D is
made by us before it's not really a
vitamin because we make it in our skin
when we get the spawns when we get
exposed to the Sun this compound is
called holocausto and once released in
the blood ends up in the liver where is
modified by the observation position 25
the compound the ensuing compound is
called 25 a dot C vitamin d3 which is
which has a half-life about two weeks
and that's important because that is the
compound we measure to find out whether
we are sufficient circulating levels of
vitamin D colleague also instead as a
half level only 24 hours after
deformation of 25 I grow at Roxy vitamin
d3 or 2500hd this compound ends up in
the kidney but also in other organs in
in the kidney there is a second
modification hydroxylation position 1
which makes the mature hormone 125 diet
Roxy vitamin d3 this is a powerful
molecule and this is the one that is
responsible for bone mineralization
sorption calcium very interesting
reabsorption in the kidney however the
the talk the the topic of this talk will
not be much at all on bone
mineralization but on other topics which
actually can be more important for the
important more important food
or justifying the relevance of vitamin D
in in in our help so we will be talking
today about vitamin d3 that's the animal
form of vitamin D the platform is called
vitamin D do but it's just for your
information in good condition seen in
conditions in which we make plenty of
cholecalciferol or vitamin d3 which is
stuff that you essentially find at the
drugstore at walmart and all the
compartments which have to do with
vitamin d metabolism are full and happy
what most people don't realize is that
in real life the only compatible which
stays full is essentially one which is
to do with the kidney because plasma
levels of 125 h2d are crucial
essentially for our survival and for
maintaining the appropriate calcium
levels in the serum however all the
other compartments are really deficient
and this affects a lot of other
functions which have nothing to do with
all but we share a lot to do with our
web we'll be in terms of diabetes cancer
and Alzheimer's disease so we really act
to tackle the importance of vitamin D
supplementation in order to prevent this
dire situation which is extremely common
in African Americans so when we go to
the pool in our trunks and we spend some
good time having a good time at the pool
we basically make about twenty thousand
international units of vitamin D that's
a lot of vitamin D and and which is why
you know but by the end of a full day we
feel very good this may I want to make
the point that 20,000 units of vitamin D
are non-toxic because actually when you
leave the pool you feel very well so the
problem is that in African Americans
there is Melanie Melanie actually works
as a shield and
daily tenfold longer time exposure to be
exposed to the Sun in order to make a
sufficient level and at our latitudes
that's really problematic so in real
life people that live in sub-saharan
Africa do not have a problem as long as
they are exposed to the Sun rather than
living inside or being heavily coated if
you go up north or porch if you go down
side now vitamin D levels will be lower
in the winter because of the angle of
the sunlight and of course if you go
further the Lord there is really a
problem because for more than six months
people cannot make their own vitamin B
so supplementation has become an
important issue also because if you
spend too much time in the Sun your
dermatologist we yell at you so you
really supplementation is really a way
to achieve the levels which are good for
a profit for your well-being and how do
we know that melanin is a shield well we
know because it turns out that ninety
seven percent of the people of European
descent ninety-seven percent again ever
mutation in this gene this gene is
essentially one responsible for
producing melanin in in our skin indeed
gene apparently got to dated six to ten
thousand years ago when essentially the
agricultural societies were established
at that time the diet changed
dramatically and rather than getting
vitamin D through the food mostly raw
meat people became suddenly deficient
and it is speculated that this created a
collapse of the hip bones because of
deficient calcification and that created
a problem for women delivering their
children so this mutation allow that
to be overcome and and it's amazing the
fact that I mutational to occur to a lot
for vitamin D to be processed is it
tells you how important that has been in
for in evolution and import Darwinian
selection so if we look at the evolution
of the human species if we look at the
evolution of human species we know that
people african-american I'm sorry
Africans living in sub-saharan Africa
generally appropriate levels and things
change when we go to up higher latitudes
and especially in the winter so
supplementation can compensate for that
but as you can see 1,000 units per day
which is what most physicians concern
council the patients due to take is
really not sufficient to reach blood
levels which are comparable to the ones
that we should have about 120 animals
which is essentially 40 to 50 nanograms
per ml 0 0 so we really need to take
4,000 units but they at least in Y 4,000
units per day because 4,000 units per
day is what is called a tolerable upper
level intake for vitamin d3 and these in
pay this level has been established by
the Food and Nutrition Board of the
Institute of Medicine this is an
important recommendation and this is the
dose that we have been using for our
clinical trials because these clinical
trials had to go through a scrutiny of
the FDA and the FDA will listen to the
IOM recommendations it's important that
however the the general recommendation
is for 600 units of vitamin D birthday
in everyone from a 200 pound
about to an eight-pound baby and you
know so it tells you that these
recommendations may not be adequate and
and certainly it's good that we have
some upper-level intake tolerable upper
level in big at least to pursue our
studies so the bottom line is the
minimum levels of vitamin D are
sufficient to prevent records but we
need much more than that for other
functions that we will be discussing
very shortly and certainly for what we
call normal functions normal actions
affect all those organs which make their
own vitamin D Orman but rather than as a
releasing it logically does which is the
only endocrine organ in terms of vitamin
D production all the other organs the
prostate the breast the skin the brain
they sequester it and in in those dishes
vitamin D words of agronomy of course if
they don't have sufficient amounts of
cholecalciferol again vitamin d3 in the
individuals do not assume sufficient
amounts of vitamin d3 they simply will
not have enough substrate to make your
own porno for their use in each other so
how do we know that vitamin D is
important for cancer well that was
really the result the serendipitous
result of a study that actually was
looking a spontaneous fractures in bone
mineralization and the study involved
about 1,200 women and they were
randomized to a number of different
conditions one of which was vitamin D
plus 1,100 units of the d3 birthday and
they were followed for this was a
four-year trial so was a long long trial
and interestingly the
revealed sunny which was totally
surprising so it turns out that the most
important outcome of this study was the
number of events cancer events
experienced by each arm and you can see
that the arm that at both calcium
vitamin D had half of the cancel events
experienced by the possible arm and so
all of a sudden we paid attention to
resolve this very well run clinical
study which was longitudinal and
carefully monitored so let's go back to
the main topic of this talk which is
that our organs other than kidney make
your own vitamin D and as I told the
basic west street and works locally the
macrophages which was to do a lot of is
one of the most important cells which
are part of the our immune response the
skin of course colon prostate breast and
gray and and so the in these organs be
the hormone is the 125 is being produced
synthesized and works on and works on a
nuclear receptor which is the vitamin D
receptor and then there is an
association with a co-receptor and these
complex binds to what I to vitamin D
response elements vitamin D response
elements of the video e are extremely
interesting sequences which are in the
promoter part of a gene and therefore
regulate the transcription meaningless
pressure of that particular G pain to a
to a fairly recent town there are about
at 1000 volunteers
response elements in the genome which
suggests that about a thousand one
thousand genes in the genome are
responsive to bottom and the action and
so if if you are not if you're deficient
that basically does not happen and that
is a problem because these genes had to
do with aunty proliferation in human
immune regulation activities so this
means that these genes control the rate
at which cells multiply and our immune
response which is fundamental to keep a
selfie from cancer so vitamin D in
prostate is a topic that has been
interesting to me for many years the
main reason is the prostate cancer is
often times in England disease and so
basically would be an ideal cancer to on
which to test a really non-toxic
intervention which can which is patient
friendly and essentially the subject can
self Medicaid doesn't have to come the
clinic and we can monitor the compliance
of subjects enrolled in a study by which
to the fact that their vitamin D levels
have to go up if you are compliant so
process cells have the vitamin D
receptor they make their own console
trial which is the hormonal form of
vitamin D D 125 or h2 the d3 and it's
well established that this kind of that
this organ can inhibit both in vivo and
in vitro cell proliferation of prostate
cells so the that was certainly a valid
rationale for treating people with
supplementation and see whether their
cancers were affected this socratis
slide that I want to I want to point out
your attention essentially two things
did one of the actions of vitamin DS on
cell cycle arrest
meaning vitamin B allows the cells to
slow down in terms of proliferation the
other thing I want to point out that
your attention is the action the bottom
Andy is in mitigating the activation of
nf-kappa B what is NF Kappa B nf-kappa B
is a transcription factor which is
essential in general that determines the
triggering of information in our body
and so nf-kappa B is a transcription
factor which binds to the promoter of a
lot of cytokines which are released when
the body experiences phenomenon of
information like you know having the flu
or things of that sort why is that
important because information really has
been a clearly demonstrated as a
cofactor in the progression of cancer
and in case of prostate cancer you can
go from non clinically relevant prostate
cancer to clinical clinically relevant
prostate cancer but anyway all of these
actions are promoted by the Domini and
they essentially all in DB inhibitors
not only your cancer progression but
also fatal cancer like inhibition of
invasion and metastasis so we design a
first prospective study to find out
whether there was any effect of vitamin
D and our first objective was to see
whether they were effects on PSA so we
enrolled subjects get a diagnosed
prostate cancer because of biology but
we look for subject with gleason score
of six or less we got an IND we have
paid an IND to perform the study from
the FDA to make sure that we were
monitored for any toxicity and I can
tell you there was none um so the
subjects diagnosed with Lori's prostate
cancer we're decided to be monitored by
something called active surveillance in
other words they deferred definitive
treatment because the cancer actually
may never progress it's it's well
established that most men die with
prostate cancer but not a prostate
cancer so and frankly treatments like
surgery is special but also the ocean
therapy have side effects significant
like impotence and incontinence and so
active surveillances is entirely
adequate for low-risk prostate cancer
for cases in which there is no impending
progression of the cancer the primary
objective was really look at whether
vitamin D given for one year at four
thousand international units per day add
an impact on on the PSA levels and as a
secondary objective we wanted to compare
the outcome of prostate biopsy which is
do which is perform periodically to find
out whether the cancer progresses in
other words if there are positive course
which are increasing in number or
increasing in severity so with this in
mind let me tell you about the
diagnostic workup for prostate cancer
probably most of you are aware but
currently a 12-course of tissue from the
prostate are acquired by the urologist
and essentially fixed and stained in
exile but otologist the course which are
the most important the one on the
outside or on the outside part of line
which is the peripheral zone because
that is the path or gland in which a new
cancers tend to emerge so once you add
this kind of test first of all the
pathology will the pathology will tell
you whether or not any cancer is
detected a neat cancer is detected will
give an estimation of the severity by
using the Gleason score if the Gleason
score is up to six it's most likely that
the the cancer is is low risk if the
Gleason score is more than six
then an extended discussion as to occur
between the patient ecologist to decide
on possible interventions anyway we only
roll subject that Gleason score of six
or less and subjects therefore who
decided to to selected not much for
waiting but monitoring of their cancer
so active surveillance so at the end of
this study we notice that actually there
was a drop in the subjects we enrolled
and which were supplemented and we knew
that they were supplemented because the
vitamin D levels went up to about 16 and
grand supreme Allah soon so obviously
they were prob'ly and we compare these
with historical controls in which case
naturally the number of possibles go up
over time so that was comforting but
even so we really needed to run a
randomized study which is what we are
running now and I'll let you know
shortly about an interim analysis we're
done or that study which is still
continuing that rule so as after this
study will learn something that was
quite interesting so this graph shows
you what a baseline what are the levels
of vitamin D between african-american
subjects and in white subjects and the
difference is really significant in
other words other government subjects
tend to be much more prone to being
vitamin D deficient not so the white
subjects however after only two months
after only two months of supplementation
there was really no significant
difference between the two groups and
actually at one year of supplementation
the two groups were indistinguishable
however we paid attention to the fact
that two months was sufficient to
eliminate differences across rates and
so and these was
important to design an additional study
after the random I studied we were still
running to look at what happens in the
prostate in the tissue using some fairly
advanced techniques one which is called
RNA sequencing so I'll skip this slide
because I may not be as before motive
for you so the the difference in vitamin
D levels between the two groups which
was very clear and has been documented
by a lot of investigators is important
because it turns out that racial
disparities in prostate cancer Adams
mirror racial difference in situating
levels of vitamin D so and this is
important because the mortality of by
prostate cancer of african-americans is
way way up and much higher than the wet
subjects so we ask the question what
happens if we supplement subjects that a
vendor gum biopsy have decided to
undergo prostatectomy and supplemental
in mean time and what happens to their
tissues so why is that okay so two
months it seems to be a sufficient
interval of time to eliminate
differences across race the other thing
is the other point is there is for
standard of care two months Aaron
interval required between the biopsy the
prostatectomy because the information of
the gland has to be s to a day before
surgery is performed so a camel surgery
we are the opportunity to evade no new
classic tissue from these subjects and
essentially track purify DNA and perform
what is called RNA sequencing RNA
sequence
is a cup is a very new approach it's a
felony approach to essentially get the
sequence of all the possible transcripts
from a piece of tissue from a particular
study subject in in practical terms this
means that each subject will be
identified by 20,000 data points because
that's very close to the number of genes
that each subject has and so we have a
very large number of the set of data to
look at woodys expression within the
prostate weed and without
supplementation and across races so this
is a fancy slide which tells you that we
use Mariner messenger RNA extraction and
we perform our sequencing and for doing
these things you need complex machines
you need and for the analysis of the
data you need supercomputers no big deal
these things are now available in most
academic medical centers and this is
another offensive slide tells you that
you need a lot of computing power in
order to analyze this data but this is
the table of subjects we enroll we
enrolled a total of twenty-seven subject
17 locations and 10 african-americans
and 17 locations where used as a control
and the african-american patients were
the experimental however each group was
randomized to other two other vitamin D
supplementation or not so the one
indicates the subject that we're
supporting them you can see for instance
that in this particular subject their
levels a baseline increased rapidly
after two months to considerable levels
so this was a prospective intervention
study with the purpose of analyzing the
expression of the RNA in within the
prostate tissue
across race and depending on
supplementation so this is some research
which tells you that apparently seek was
performed on the RNA of 27 patients
using two distinct instruments to bound
eight the data and then we and the data
and when what is called integrity
analysis what is the the purpose of that
the purpose is to see how significant
are any differences if there are and the
difference were incredibly significant
and they're really surprised us the
first thing we found was that more than
three thousand genes were expressed enid
differently between african-americans
and whites at a false discovery rate of
point one which is extremely extremely
significant this was really not a fluke
and we know that it was not from other
data elbows and the other thing is that
a full discovery of point 40.4 which is
less stringent but still significant be
the number of genes which were
differentials press press were more than
eight times and that's about one-third
of the genome that is again we were very
surprised and so we dug into the data to
understand a little bit more about that
so and the kind of an ass that you can
perform when you have so many data which
we know that to understand what they
mean is you suck looking for pathways
and the impact on several components the
impact of biological processes and there
are highly sophisticated programs they
allow you to log a pathway analysis in
other words do the question was do these
differential expressed genes cluster
according to certain pathways and
certain cellular functions and the
answer actually was yes the conclusion
and you know our paper had like 16
figures the
Lucien is that average American subjects
showed a higher expression of genes
associated with the new response and
information which are to the
characteristic targets essential vitamin
D supplementation and considering that
African Americans tend to be vitamin D
deficient that was not surprising what
surprises was the extent of differential
expression and so essentially that was
an indicator of the severity the problem
the other thing was that when we analyze
the data a little bit more in detail
according to these various pathways the
results were very clear so on the right
here the ten columns representing each
african-american subject on the left 17
counts representing each you bein
subject and read increase indicates
overexpression blue indicates under
expression and it's very clear that for
a lot of pathway that have are
intimately involved we essentially the
immune response in general the
difference was very clear and very
striking also want to point your
attention to the difference is found in
NF Kappa B signaling which specifically
is affected by rattin TV any gain once
again there were clear differences
between the two racial groups so does
this mean anything well there was a
paper published in 2008 by Wallace and
coworkers they use a different
technology which was not as advanced
because that was 2008 and they use
something called mathematics by using
that and that was actually a
retrospective study but by using their
distich need they identified almost 500
genes with which were differential
splash between expressed between blacks
and whites so what we did we look at
those treats and essentially we captured
all of them so basically our results
confirm that kind of analysis
and also confirm the results you see the
african americans are only bread the
Europeans are in blue so this is
tremendous racial difference which go to
the biological level and so not only we
capture that but we also demonstrated
that these differences are much more
extensive just by which to the fact that
what we use was among more advanced
technology and this is just a chart to
show you that there were differences at
the beginning in terms of vitamin D
levels and that these differences were
compensated in African Americans using
only 2014 only two months using photos
and units per day and that basically at
the end of the treatment there were no
differences between african-americans
and whites ataxic with being
supplemented with vitamin D so what
happens to the gene expression after bad
Amanda selection well we basically found
that about 350 genes were motivated bear
in mind visuals and intervention that
was only two months and effect and we
analyzed the effects of these
supplementation only at a profit level
however keep in mind that if you had
disciplined economy one year a longer
these overlap would be much much larger
and so when we looked at the the type of
genes that were altered in expression by
the vitamin D treatment essentially got
the same response that we got previously
Troy meany chemokine receptors and G
protein-coupled sectors which
essentially our controllers of cell
proliferation so again these results are
really consistent with the fact that
vitamin D does affect those pathways
which may be relevant in the progression
from
[Music]
from Louis cancer to her it's cancer and
that is particularly serious among
african-americans so the last thing we
did was to lock a possible differences
between within the african-american code
between the ones that were supplemented
with that I mean either ones which
receive food is impossible and once
again we found significant differences
124 genes were differentially regulated
at a full secure data point one which is
again extremely stranger and one of the
surprises was that one of the genes
affected is the junior 15 which is a
gene which is important for prostate
cancer progression which was actually
activated by them it's activated by
vitamin D and actually in that cohort
that receive the treatment basically was
upregulated so let me tell you a little
bit about now the ongoing randomized
study the supplementation which occurs
for one year in subjects that are
enrolled that go for the weblog glorious
prostate cancer who undergo work
monitored by active surveillance and
basically a randomized to other possible
here you have the preliminary is the
ethical subjects environmentally by now
we should be about hundred subjects and
counting and the first thing is that
vitamin D supplementation works so in
the possible arm there is no difference
between the recent if she wasn't blacks
but essentially the baseline values are
not terribly changed d but with vitamin
D supplementation the exit values are
way different much higher and this means
that these people are compliant we
really had no problems with combines we
really cannot think of any subjects that
did not take their vitamin D which again
is non-toxic
easy to assume because they do it on
their own guitar so first thing we
looked at this PSA and again PSA really
did not watch between the two groups
these are the the collected data for
both groups and again these confirms
what we saw in in the if you look at if
you look at the p-values there is really
no difference ok so the PSA doesn't
change again this is confirmatory of the
open-label study what changes is the at
the moment that is trying toward a
decrease of the positive course is
repeat biopsy in subjects who receive
barramundi and what's interesting is
that this trend is particularly clear in
the african-american part of the study
in the subjects in african-american
subjects which to us makes sense because
these are the subjects who tend to be
vitamin D deficient to begin with there
is really not much of a difference in
white subjects again they time to start
with decent levels of vitamin D at
baseline so the study is still growing
and we hope to find out that by the end
of a cruel and the end of analysis these
differences may be significant so this
is where African African Americans are
in terms of vitamin D levels they are
really added a vision of insufficient
and they should be here this is what
they should be they should be replete
and that would allow for I think a
mitigation of the hell disparities not
only in terms of prostate cancer but
also diabetes and hypertension so that's
really the object to encourage these
people
to get supplementation on their own um
this is a cartoon that was lent to me by
dr. Bruce Hollis who's really a
well-respected in vitamin D I want to
make two points that there are certain
actions of vitamin D which are not be
needed by gene expression in other words
they are immediately or direct and they
are due to the cholecalciferol it has to
do with the endothelium stabilization
and is something that actually has been
has been used to justify massive doses
of vitamin d3 admission into the ICU to
prevent septic shock um the other thing
i want to point your attention is that
vitamin d goes to the brain and again
the brain is all the enzymes to make it
so Norman so cholecalciferol goes to the
brain through a mega lean mediated
mechanism just like in the placenta and
in the brain the vitamin D becomes the
vitamin D hormone because the brain is
all as the vitamin D receptor in older
enzymes to make its own but a mini coma
why is this relevant because in the
central nervous system vitamin D
controls the production of two important
hormones Negra factor ngf and Goliath
Arab neurotrophic factor or gdnf and
these are important molecules that
essentially protect integrity were on
our new ones not only but latter mainly
because 0 is anti-inflammatory action is
essentially a protector against suddenly
called nirajan neurodegenerative
diseases and the worst one which is
Alzheimer disease so what we did was to
test in an animal model of Alzheimer
disease whether a diet rich in vitamin D
might have been helpful or could give us
some indication of whether
might have been effective it's slowing
down or correcting the problems
associated with Alzheimer's disease now
ultimate disease is in the animal model
in question which is called the APB
mouths amyloid precursor protein in this
animal model the transgene is a Swedish
equivalent of an altered amyloid
precursor proteins which produce large
amounts of the a beta peptide near beta
beta peptide is essentially a seed for
what we call amyloid plaques which are
visible in the brain of people were
affected by Alzheimer's no don't advise
but also human beings so this is a
convenient model to study corrective
actions of intervention which may slow
down or prevent Alzheimer's disease and
so what we did was to randomize mice to
other regular diet or a vitamin D which
diet or a diet without identity and the
mice will run the lines immediately
after winning and they were kept on
these particular diets for five months
at five months the mice were euthanized
but before doing that it might be tested
for memory retention and which by the
way showed a difference but what's
important is that the brains bones and
blood the demise were collected and
analyzed and this is what we found well
we found it first of all the vitamin D
richd I brought a high level of
separating vitamin D in his mind's
compared to vitamin D deficient diet in
which really the vitamin D levels were
close to zero in certain did not budge
the second thing we found was that
indeed vitamin D is needed for bone
mineralization because on the left you
have the bone of a mouse that a vitamin
E which died on the right the bone of a
master at the bottom and D deficient
diet and there is these matrix
osteogenic matrix which looks pinkish
here which is in great
amounts in mice with vitamin D because
of course they are hungry for calcium
and there is no calcium to be found
because the culture is not absorbed
because vitamin D is not present well in
contrast in the mass receiving vitamin D
rich diet basically you could not find
under the microscope not one shred of
the osteogenic matrix because there was
plentiful calcium and everything and on
the bone was totally ossified although
totally calcified so these were they
just to make sure that the diets were
doing the job so then we went to the
brain and the brain on the left panels
you see the brains of mice at reseda
button d deficient diet on the right you
see the panel's BDF an edge referring to
the brains analyzed by two different
imaging techniques otherwise that
received a vitamin D rich side and what
you can see not only that the number of
boxes very different and they were
significant difference but what's more
important is that the size of the class
was very differently see the plugs in a
non supplemented mice were much larger
compared to the parks that we observed
in supplemented mice and actually these
kind of stuff could be this kind of
parameters could be analyzing quantified
and so here is the result so we have two
parameters animal globe which is the
total amount of amyloid in amyloid
plaques even though the unlocked plaques
in in mice which had a vitamin D
deficient part died were more than the
mice with vitamin D enriched I've the
difference in seem to be so shall we say
was significant but not spectacular but
the only little differences were
spectacular because that keeps takes
into account the the amount of amyloid
which is much watch in other words
number of blocks does not reflect the
difference dynamic load that you can
measure in the bay
the other thing we did was to look at
mediators of information and one of the
most important leaders of nearly
formation is tumor necrosis factor often
so basically teacher efforts were
prepared from brain of the mice
receiving a vitamin D deficient compared
to the mice receiving a vitamin D a rich
diet and the difference was striking so
one can object and say well you know
maybe vitamin D brings down just about
everything in the brain and to clear you
of that misconception let's see what
happens with the NGF for the nerve
protracted well the nerve growth factor
essentially increases by at least three
fall in mice receiving a vitamin D in
rich diet and is very low in mice
receiving a vitamin D deficient diet so
the point I'm trying to make is that so
you know forever in the audience is
interested in neurodegenerative diseases
please take your vitamin D go to walmart
the drugstore get your 5,000 units per
day and actually this can be really a
protector because what we see with the
elder generation now the alliteration
all the people who by the way are very
often vitamin D deficient is this
epidemics of Alzheimer so since we know
it let's use supplementation possibly
prevent these courage and of course I
could not have done these obese by
myself and these are my collaborators
and thanks to them we could bring to
fruition a lot of work and now I will
lead so on I'm done with my presentation
you know leave the word to the moderator
mr. Castle yawns
thank you so very much for your
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them and the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window will try
to answer as many questions as we can
for this event dr. our first question is
as men over 50 are in risk of prostate
cancer will you recommend that men have
daily over-the-counter vitamin d3
supplement yes absolutely yes I I
basically all my friends know that I
tell them sometimes I bring in bottles
of vitamin D in FL them to take it as
many beneficial effects but absolutely
anyone over 15 just pop your your pill
every day with your coffee and I think
that that's going to be very helpful and
you know sometimes this can be coupled
with selenium list which is another
which actually we have some old evidence
to suggest that actually the two vitamin
B and selenium actually may work
together against possible progression of
work of said cancer anyway I my answer
is a absolutely yes do not hesitate and
it's non-toxic
our next question can take in vitamin D
supplements or spending more time in the
Sun help prevent Alzheimer's and other
forms of dementia well the results of
our animal studies indicate that and
because essentially by decreasing their
information and increasing the
production of ngf and gdnf I think that
that is certainly has good a measure and
again this is non-toxic and you know if
you really want to crank up the
supplementation can go to 10,000 units
the only the only recommendation I make
is that if individual come from families
with a predisposition to kidney stones
they probably should bring quite a bit
of water just to prevent the possibility
that stones may form in the kidney but
otherwise I I can tell you to the
hundreds of patients with Blanco we have
not seen any smidgen of evidence that
vitamin E is toxic at all even at high
doses
vitamin D supplementation treat
depression or improve mood well that's
an interesting question because actually
it our medical center i know of some
psychiatrists that suggest to their
patients who experience depression to
take healthy levels of vitamin d
supplementation so again it's it's a
neurotrophic factor in other words the
simulate look when you go to the pool
and you stay you know a couple of hours
to the pool generally speaking you know
your appetite is up and you feel good
okay so I think it to have a good levels
of vitamin D probably really would
improve your mood and certainly again it
has been indicated not so much together
but certainly suggested to people who
have depressive symptoms by the way does
not interfere with anything that they
may have to take for that condition
I thank you doctor and it looks like we
have time for one last question today
are you aware of any studies with
vitamin D and treating fibromyalgia I am
not aware of any status but i would
guess my educated guess is that if there
are inflammatory components the
fibromyalgia which there are health is a
commendation vitamin d may only help and
thank you doctor and before we let you
go today do you have any final comments
for your presentation make sure you take
your vitamin d you will not be yelled at
by the dermatologist and your sense of
well-being will increase it takes about
2 months to to be replete but after that
you will expect experience that you are
in better shape you will not be prone to
colds and if you get a cold or even a
mouth to it's going to be mild indeed in
terms of duration survive I like that
once again thank the doctor for his time
and presentation I'd also like to thank
elaborate for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
februari of 2017 you receive an email
from lab roots alerting me when this
webcast will be available for replay
we'd like to invite you to Ford that
announcements to your colleagues who've
may have missed today's live
presentation until next time goodbye
you